MORGAN FREEMAN
(VOICEOVER): Ian Ball had
never been a religious person.
He never really
thought about God.
But scarring from
brain surgery brought
on a series of visions that
made him question everything.
This carried on for
about three or four weeks.
About how often?
- Every day.
- Every day?
Every morning.
I felt like I was being
sort of transported
and being revealed
fundamental truths
about the nature of reality.
One of which is that all
inanimate objects are
conscious, all beings
are conscious, including
walls, tables, and
chairs, which seemed
very counterintuitive to me.
I mean, how can you have
consciousness without a brain?
The other thing that
seem to be happening
was that everything is
bound together in one thing
by an endless
unconditional love.
And there was this
huge wave of emotion
that came with this
experience, which was
really powerful and uplifting.
MORGAN FREEMAN (VOICEOVER):
Are you religious?
I was an agnostic.
I didn't know how
to understand it.
I don't know if it was God.
You don't know that it wasn't.
I don't know that it wasn't.
I don't know what it was.
Mhm.
Ian wanted to find out
whether his visions
had a medical cause.
So he joined the
Cambridge University study
conducted by Dr. Joseph Tenant.
It was searching for a
connection between epilepsy
and mystical experiences.
That's a scan of the
tumor that was the cause
of the seizures I was having.
So I mean, as you
can see on this scan,
the growth from the skull,
the left temporal lobe.
And so this is pushing up
against Ian's the brain.
And so they had to cut
off that section away.
But obviously, when you do that,
you leave a bit of scarring
on the left temporal lobe.
So it seems something
about the temporal lobe
is potentially
capable of producing
spiritual experiences.
You have not come to any
sort of conclusions yet on it?
We can't induce a seizure on
someone of a mystical nature
and hope that we can get a
good scan of it under an MRI.
We don't know when the
seizures are happening.
Can't you come to some sort
of conclusion behind that?
Not quite yet.
I would.
I would jump right to it.
God exists.
That's Joan of Arc,
Saint Bernadette.
Do you think that
there is a possibility
that they experienced
this sort of epilepsy?
It is possible.
So there was a
neurological paper
that speculated that Paul's
vision on the road to Damascus
was epilepsy.
But I mean, so what?
Because the thing that
occurred afterwards
was Paul was moved to go
preach and become Saint Paul.
Right.
As a scientist I can't
tell you whether these
are metaphysical or not.
The thing we can look at is to
say that something in the brain
is capable of producing
religious experience
and can do so even when
it's not intending to.
All right.
Here's the $64 question.
How has it changed you?
Well, I think it
did remove any sense
of that I had that the universe
is a meaningless, cold place.
I think it gave a kind of
foundation of meaning for me.
And I think the idea
of was it a revelation
or was it just an
aberration in the brain?
I've come to the conclusion
it doesn't really matter,
because the thing that really
sticks with me is that feeling
of endless unconditional love.
And I don't think
that really matters
whether it came from a divine
force or from my damaged brain.